Here's a genius client outreach strategy
that I've never seen anyone else do.
Take something around your house that
you've bought, like this Keychron C2
that I bought off Amazon, try it out,
and go email the people who made it.
Jump on their email list, read their
emails, and say, "Hey, I bought X from
you. I spent X amount of dollars. I went
through your welcome sequence, and this
is what I learned. Here, I wrote you a
brand new welcome sequence that would
actually sell significantly more than
your current sequence. I love what you
guys are doing. I've spent money with
you guys, and I enjoy your product. Give
me an opportunity to AB test what you're
doing versus what I'm doing for free,
and if I beat what you're doing, then
let's work together on another project.
And if I don't beat it, no worries, I'll
enjoy the keyboard." Try that, and let
me know how it goes.